britney spears just revealed that she
has caught some of the documentary about
her conservatorship and
it left her in tears i say i'm crazy
hi brilliant how you doing today quote i
didn't watch the documentary but from
what i did see of it i was embarrassed
by the light they put me in
oh my goodness hello
ew i'm embarrassed can we
i cried for two weeks i still cry
sometimes
brittany broke her silence about the
framing britney spears hulu documentary
alongside this video
dancing to aerosmith's crazy
[Music]
in the lengthy instagram caption britney
says she dances to this song
every night for her sanity to quote feel
wild
and human and alive adding my life has
always been very speculated watched and
judged really my whole life
this past week brittany also gave a
shout out to some cool ladies
who have helped her during a really hard
quarantine including sharon stone
the thing with britney spears is so out
of control and so awful
today sharon revealed the surprising
backstory to their friendship
she told kelly clarkson brittany reached
out to her for help
in 2007 during the peak of her breakdown
brittany
wrote to me a very long and poignant
letter
during a very difficult time when she
shaved her head wanting me to help her
it's very hard to be a very successful
woman
and not have everyone controlling you
taking your finances
and handling you there is a huge
breaking point
it's i'm bad
britney has taken legal action to have
dad jamie spears removed from her
conservatorship
jamie has refused to step down and has
waged an expensive court battle to stay
on
now e.t has obtained court documents
showing britney is the one footing the
bill
and the cost is staggering in just five
months alone
jamie's legal team has charged nearly
900 000
which is around 10 000 a workday and all
of that money will be paid through
brittany's estate
[Music]